hola Galera the Rio major has finally
come to a close and
what a major it was the upsets the
Cinderella Stories the silver coins the
crowd and of course the saves it's fair
to say that Rio proved surprising in
more ways than one
so let's get into it
[Music]
all right before I start evangelizing
you all about our Lord and savior Jane I
just wanted to take a quick second and
let you all know that we have partnered
with the fine folks over at Predator
gaming to bring you a personalized
holiday gift guide
[Music]
there's a few things I want the first of
which is a way to ride my bike indoors
I'm a fairly serious cyclist and because
I live in Canada can't ride outside for
like half the year a simple but sturdy
fluid trainer like one of these smart
equipped Terraces should do the trick of
course it wouldn't be Christmas in the
Dimitri household without a new CS go
cosmetic this year I'm thinking of
trading up some of my lesser used High
tiers into a sapphire bayonet don't get
me wrong my BFK lore plus Pandora's is
still the end game combo for me I just
want something else to run on the side
but top of the list has to be a brand
new Decked Out gaming laptop I'm sort of
back on the road these days which means
that I need a way to counter strikes
well
globally and as it turns out the
Predator Triton 300SE lets me do just
that it's got a 12th gen Intel Core i7
processor 16 gigs of RAM Custom
Engineered Cooling and a super sick 14
inch 1920x1200 OLED display which
honestly all sounds pretty good to me be
sure to check them out on bestbuy.com if
you two are interested in copying one
alright on to the major first things
first
how y'all doing it's been a while you
know since we just got to sit down you
and me talk some shop about CS
I missed you guys for those who don't
know I spent the first week of November
in San Francisco as part of League of
Legends worlds I live streamed the final
episodes of rank up ping down with Cisco
and got to watch in person from like a
hundred feet away as DRX did The
Impossible against Faker and I mean it
when I say that it was insanely cool it
just
wasn't CS I was still watching the major
mind you
just got railroaded on my coin you see I
didn't have a computer with me which
meant that despite making it through
Challengers on track for Diamond I
couldn't actually fill out my pickums
for the legend stage the worst part is
that I predicted all four Champions
quarterfinals correctly so I was one off
gold but decided to go all in on the
memes and put Mouse to win it all since
I mean at that point I really didn't
have anything to lose this is why I need
that Predator Triton 300SE so I don't
get screwed into a silver coin anyway
coin related whining aside the upsets at
this major were insane I think it's fair
to say that we all knew that Rio was
going to be anyone's for the taking we
just didn't know that it was gonna be
any ones for the taking memes aside I
know that our boy Devin already took you
guys through the phase collapse and all
the rest of the insanity from The
Challengers and legends stages so I
won't rehash any of that what I will do
is talk about Champions because
man what a ride that was first off mouse
imagine thinking these guys wouldn't
take down Cloud9 kind of cringe to be
honest despite being mostly an academy
roster most displayed calm nerves and
the synergistic Trust of a seasoned
experienced side zershin was a literal
turret Dexter just showed insane
resilience and Frozen is finally finally
getting the recognition as the god to
your rifler he has always been it is
insane that these guys went as deep as
they did and
boy what's the crowd here for it this
crowd oh this crowd has rolled out the
red carpet for the NXT Generation
speaking of that crowd it is fair to say
that the world of Counter-Strike has
never seen
anything like it especially when it came
time for Hometown Heroes Furia to face
off against
simple okay serato's gonna do it alone
oh denied by some guy young
oh it's simple as China and pop up the
crowd even more and when they finally
took him down
dude
what a display
undeterred have their sights
[Applause]
all the way until the very
now
area and they've seen this man at Shaw
and Perfecto acceptance
yeah
let's go
suffice it to say that may have actually
been the series of the tournament I have
never seen or heard anything like that
ever and while it is true that the crowd
wasn't as present for the later
match-ups as they could have been I
personally think that they more than
made up for it when Brazil actually
played Plus
let's just be honest any series of which
Outsiders is apart
sort of residence labor now I want to be
abundantly clear I have the utmost
respect for Outsiders I have been
defending the Jane Dustin quicker core
against online or allegations for ages
and while I could never have predicted
that they would win the major I swore
that they would make top eight that said
they can be very very boring to watch
and as hype as Canadian is pitting
Outsiders against a precise Danish
Powerhouse like heroic
not my idea of a Perfect final
and it wasn't
far from it
it was sort of a blowout with every
passing second of that bomb The
Outsiders prepared
to start their celebration now to be
fair that is largely because Outsiders
are just that difficult to dismantle for
those who are somehow unaware with
Outsiders and the memes surrounding
their Opera and igl's ostensibly
unhealthy obsession with saving
otherwise known as Jane time they've
basically managed to min max every
conceivable aspect of csgo's in-game
economy the running joke is that
Outsiders are paid by the round since
their risk averse playstyle often
results in their matches going way
longer than any other teams that said
there were absolutely times when
Outsiders straight up held W against
their opponents and one very notable
instance where Jane decided he was not
in fact going to save I don't even think
James realizes he could actually save he
probably feels like there's presence in
the b-bomb site but the clutch is on oh
that smoke it catches the real and
that's a little bit unfortunate
otherwise we maybe you're gonna try to
improve some pressure he's still gonna
go for it he picks up that one oh no
game are you kidding me he actually
picks up the round he said he was boring
he's got you on your feet the question
is whether other rosters will finally
start to take Outsiders off to memed
upon playstyle a little more seriously
kind of like how everyone started taking
notes from astralis back when they were
revolutionizing utility in 2018. I
actually think it was one of our viewers
who happened to comment on the James
offbeat who put it best what's shocking
about Jane to me is not that he saves so
much it's that he's the first person to
save this much while the final itself
did prove to be an underwhelming finish
to an otherwise remarkable major I
really do think it's just because
Outsiders were that far ahead of the
competition they were by far the best
team at the major and by God did it show
say what you will about James weird
Frugal fragging his time has come and he
isn't a anymore well he isn't but he's
also a major winner
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite-sized videos you won't find
anywhere else hit us up on our Twitter
Instagram Facebook and tick tock